-Christoph, welcome to the show.
It is --
It is so great to have you here.
-Thank you.
-Christopher!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wait.
You can yell "Christopher,"
and you answer to that?
Or did you say
"Christoph Valz"?
What'd you yell?
-"Christoph Vy."
-Christoph "Vy" --
"Valts," "Veitz," "Valz"?
"Veitz," "Valtz."
-Well,
"Yimmy" Fallon should know.
-Oh, my gosh!
This is ridiculous.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Jimmy, Jimmy.
Thank you
for coming back to the show.
-No, thank you for having me.
-I know, you know,
you used to live in New York.
You were --
-Ah, yes, those were the days.
Actually, lived here during
the beginning of the end.
[ Laughter ]
-What are you talking about?
-Well, I'm talking about
the late '70s and early '80s
of the 20th century.
That's when I was in New York.
-Please.
[ Laughter ]
-Now it's trying to be New York.
-What "it's trying
to be New York"?
No, we are New York.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not trying to be New York.
-Not by comparison.
-Well, I mean --
-Who's old enough to -- right?
Prove me right.
-I mean, this has happened.
This is New York. I mean,
we were talking back there.
You told me you're not even
a fan of the cold weather.
-Well, cold, yes, that's true.
It's cold.
But, you know, I notice --
I wonder, are there stores
where people can go
to get a New York outfit?
Let me look like a New Yorker.
[ Laughter ]
It really --
Sometimes I feel it's --
They all have
their private costume designers
that say, "No, no, no.
You just look like
a regular person today.
You need to put this on.
You want to look like
a New Yorker.
You're in New York."
You know?
"That's where the store is
where you go
buy your New Yorker outfit."
-Yeah. Why are you so worried
and concerned?
This is -- what you're wearing
is a New Yorker outfit.
-Well, maybe it's envy.
[ Laughter ]
-What are you talking --
You're envious of other people's
style, sense of style maybe?
-Well, they're really --
a lot of them really look good.
-I know!
[ Laughter ]
But you -- you look good
in everything.
You were saying backstage to me,
right before the show --
this is true --
that you were nervous
even of what jacket to wear.
-Well, because it's cold.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah,
and you want to look cool.
Well, here's the deal.
We have -- I have three jackets.
[ Laughter ]
I have one, two --
These are parkas.
And we have voting clickers
at our seats.
[ Cheers ]
The whole night's show
we're voting on what we like
and don't like.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Would you like to --
Christoph, would you like
to try on some coats
and see what the audience
likes you in?
-Can we vote about you, too?
-No, no, no.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Let's start with this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I have these three -- yeah.
We'll come back here.
And we're not sure which one
you want to put on first.
Just these three ones here.
Maybe, yeah.
You want to try that one?
-Okay.
-You pick one.
I'll reintroduce you.
You come out,
and then we'll judge you.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Ladies and gentlemen,
Christoph Waltz.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughs ]
Wow!
Yes.
I like that a lot.
This is option number one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Option number one,
cast your vote.
Thumbs up or thumbs down,
option --
Let's see -- let's see.
The votes are in.
Let's see
what the audience said.
Wow!
That's good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's good.
That's really good.
All right. Ready?
-That's green.
-It actually looks good.
Yes, it's green.
It looks good.
I love this.
-Green steel.
-Yeah, green steel.
I love it, it's good.
[ Laughter ]
Try -- let's try -- try this.
We'll try coat number two.
Here we go.
I like this one.
That one's a winner for me.
I like that.
He looked good in that.
I haven't seen that jacket
really so much.
It was kind of different.
I kind of dug it.
All right, here we go.
Ladies and gentlemen,
here in New York,
during the cold weather,
is Christoph Waltz, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh!
Oh-ho!
That's a stud.
See, that's
what I'm talking about.
That's a good-looking guy.
I like him.
He's kind of --
You're kind of mysterious.
Almost a --
-No, orange steel.
-No, I know, orange steel.
I know, but, no, but you also
came out kind of like,
"I don't know
what this guy's deal is.
Did he just come off the docks?"
[ Laughter ]
"Is he a fisherman?"
I'm just intrigued by him.
I think this one works.
Everyone cast your vote,
thumbs up or thumbs down.
Be honest.
He can take it.
-Don't be honest!
-No, he can handle it.
The votes are in.
Let's see the results on this,
on option number two.
Oh, no, wow!
Get -- get out.
We don't want to see it.
Never happened, never happened.
The green one's in the lead.
This is the third, and --
That never happened.
All right, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
This is first time.
This is the best.
I love it.
All right, here we go.
Ladies and gentlemen,
here he is, ready to
walk down the street
in New York,
in the winter weather,
Christoph Waltz!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause
continues ]
♪♪
Oh!
[ Laughs ]
I like this one, too.
I like this --
He was definitely mysterious.
Like, he kind of had
a little groove to him.
Did a little step,
a little pep in his step.
Everyone take your votes.
I think I kind of know
what the winner's gonna to be.
Come on over.
What do you think?
Christoph,
what are you thinking?
-I think it's, um...
You didn't have a blue one.
I wanted to do my blue steel.
-That's kind of bl--
[ Laughter ]
That is kind of blue.
That's kind of blue.
All right.
Let's see the results
of this third one.
The third one, the last one,
that is the winner right there!
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Are you gonna --
-Would you come down here,
all the way up there?
The guy with the beard?
Would you come down here,
please?
Quick!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Come, come!
Quick, quick, quick, run, run!
-Oh, my gosh!
Why, because --
Oh, please.
What in the -- oh, my gosh.
You're getting a jac--
You're getting a coat?
Because you know how to say
it -- pronounce his name?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Off you go.
-Get out of here!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-He could -- He could
pronounce my name properly.
-Yes, I know.
He could, actually.
[ Applause ]
[ Laughs ]
You are the best.
You are the -- we love you.
Wow, that guy is so psyched.
He got a great coat out of this.
[ Laughter and cheers ]
-Well, there --
-That's what you get
for being a fan, right?
Yeah.
-What you get
for saying my name.
-No, I'm sorry.
Christoph.
Let's just --
Can I just call you Christoph?
[ Laughter ]
Let's talk about...
-If you can say it.
-..."The Consultant."
"The Consultant."
This is a twisty --
a twisty mystery, thriller.
I love it.
-Thank you.
-I don't want
to give anything away.
I don't want to spoil it.
-You couldn't.
[ Laughter ]
-I could.
I will not, though.
I will not.
-Okay, sorry.
-Well, maybe I can say --
What could I say?
But you are a consultant.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, okay, okay, okay.
We agree on that.
-Shows up after a C.E.O. of
a video-game company is killed.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
And the consultant comes in
and starts making some changes
that not everyone's happy about.
[ Laughter ]
You are ruthless!
You are sinister!
-"Sinister" is a beautiful word.
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Is it fair to say
you are a villain?
-A what?
-Are you --
Are you a villain in this?
-No.
[ Laughter ]
Um, w-why?
-You know --
-I said you couldn't, really,
and I was right.
[ Laughter ]
-I think I set it up
pretty well, right?
You guys know what it's about,
kind of?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-All right?
-All right, good.
Have I said enough?
-Sure.
-I want to show a clip.
Here's Christoph Waltz
in "The Consultant."
-Not bad.
-Not bad?
-No, for a start.
-Take a look.
[ Laughter ]
-Good morning, comrades.
Unfortunately, Mr. Sang
cannot be with us today,
but he sends his best regards.
[ Quiet gasps, murmurs ]
To the wonderful faces
I see below,
thank you for being an important
part in Compware's success.
I'm looking forward to getting
to know you all personally.
You're valued.
And for those who work remotely,
you have exactly one hour
to get here in person,
or your contracts of employment
will be terminated.
That's all.
-Yeah!
That's how do you do it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Christoph Waltz, everybody!
"The Consultant" premieres
February 24th on Prime Video!
Tig Notaro
joins us after the break.
Stick around.